,
CHOOSING HIS WORDS CAREFULLY
WHILE SUGGESTING HIS
DEMONSTRATION COULD LOOK INTO
MUSK'S FOREIGN TIES.
>> ELON MUSK'S...
COOPERATION AND/OR...
TECHNICAL RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES IS WORTHY OF
BEING LOOKED AT.
>> Jessica: SO, GREG --
>> Greg: YES?
WHAT WAS WRONG WITH HIM?
I DON'T KNOW.
HE IS DYING.
HOW LONG DID IT TAKE HIM TO SAY
SIX WORDS?
>> Jessica: HE WAS CHOOSING
HIS WORDS CAREFULLY.
>> Greg: HE WASN'T --
JOE BIDEN IS SAYING YOU SHOULD
LOOK INTO SOMEBODY ELSE'S
FOREIGN TIES?
CAN YOU SAY UKRAINE?
CAN YOU SAY CHINA?
ARE YOU OUT OF YOUR MIND?
HE HAS NO CONCEPT OF WHAT PEOPLE
DO IN THIS WORLD TO MAKE THE
WORLD BETTER.
HE HAS DEMONIZED INDIVIDUALS WHO
DO THEIR JOBS.
HE IS STEALING FROM AMERICAN
WORKERS TO GIVE TO PEOPLE WHO
WILL NOT PAY OFF THEIR LOANS, HE
HAS CRAPPED ON SO MANY PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T VOTE FOR HIM,
HE IS GOING AFTER SOMEONE
EXPANDING THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
HE IS ALWAYS ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF EVERYTHING, BUT HEY, AT LEAST
HE IS A NICE GUY.
>> Jeanine: HAS A LIAR.
>> Greg: BUT HE HAS SUCH A
NICE GUY, JUDGE.
>> Jeanine: NO --
>> Greg: HE'S A NICE GUY.
>> Jeanine: IS NOT A NICE GUY.
>> Greg: I AM BEING SARCASTIC.
>> Jessica: SO THE REASON HE
IS SAYING THIS IS BECAUSE THERE
IS A SAUDI PRINCE AND HIS
INVESTMENT FIRM, THE TWO BIGGEST
STAKEHOLDER IN TWITTER,
WE KNOW THERE WAS A SAUDI SPY
THAT WAS WORKING WITH TWITTER,
SPYING ON DISSIDENTS.
WE ALSO KNOW THE SAUDIS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KILLING
JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS INSANE?
>> Jeanine: WHAT ABOUT THE
CHINESE?
THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE OVER --
>> Jessica: TIKTOK IS A
COMPLETE DANGER TO ALL OF US.
>> Jeanine: YOU HAVE SWALWELL,
FEINSTEIN, THE CHINESE
INFILTRATING.
I DON'T THINK
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN BEING
INVESTIGATED.
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
YOU WANT TO ANSWER THIS?
YEAH, I THINK THE WHOLE THING IS
RICH, IT IS JUST A TOTALLY RICH
HYPOCRISY THAT CAN ONLY HAPPEN
WITH THIS PRESIDENT, WHO HATES
ANYBODY WHO IS NOT A DEMOCRAT,
AND HE HAS LIED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, SAYING NOTHING ABOUT HIS
SON'S BUSINESS DEALINGS, TONY
BOBULINSKI IS THE ONLY GUY WHO
CAME OUT, THE FBI WANTED TO
INTERVIEW ANYONE ELSE COMING ON
TO TALK ABOUT FRAUD, YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT OTHER GOVERNMENTS,
THEY WENT THROUGH EUROPE WITH A
GARBAGE BAG AND A VACUUM CLEANER
SUCKING UP THE MONEY.
FROM ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NO INTEREST IN AMERICA AND BEING
FREE.
ELON MUSK BUYS TWITTER AND
PEOPLE ARE NOW WHAT WORRIED, OH,
MY GOD, THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE ANY
LOCKDOWN ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THIS.
>> Jessica: OKAY.
DANA, THE IMPERSONATING PROBLEM
THAT IS HAPPENING ON TWITTER
NOW, WE WERE TALKING EARLIER
ABOUT THIS, ELI LILLY TWEET THAT
WAS UP THE ARTS BEFORE IT
HAPPENS TO LeBRON JAMES.
I DON'T ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
IS GOING ON THE BLUE CHECK MARK
THEN, BUT OBVIOUSLY IT NEEDS
SOME FINE TUNING, AND I AM SURE
THEY ARE WORKING ON IT OVER AT
TWITTER BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOT TO
GET A HANDLE ON IT AND THEY HAVE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE
SURE ADVERTISERS STAY,
ET CETERA.
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO KEEP IT
GOING?
GIVE THEM A MINUTE.
THE OWNER FOR SEVEN DAYS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, I THINK
EGGS NEED TO SETTLE DOWN, BUT I
THINK HE IS THEY WANT TO DO
THAT.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT JOE BIDEN
SEEMS TO HAVE SOMETHING AGAINST
ELON MUSK GOING WAY BACK.
DO YOU GUYS REMEMBER AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WHEN THEY INVITED ALL OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE BUT THEY
WOULD NOT INVITE HIM.
THEY SENT A LETTER.
SOME SPECULATED BECAUSE HE DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR UNIONIZATION AT
HIS PLANTS, AND SO ELON MUSK HAS
BEEN IN THE CROSSHAIRS OF
JOE BIDEN FOR A LONG TIME, AND
NOW HE IS A CONVENIENT FOIL.
THE BEST THING FOR JOE BIDEN IS
TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO BE FIGHTING
AGAINST, TO BE PUSHING AGAINST,
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
GOING ALONG WITH THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS ENDS, IN
TERMS OF THE BLUE CHECK MARK OR
TWITTER OR ANYTHING.
I LIKE IT FOR A LOT OF REASONS,
I AM EXCITED ABOUT MORE PEOPLE
BEING ABLE TO BE ON, SHARING
THEIR IDEAS, BUT I REALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY FIGURE OUT THIS
BLUE CHECK MARK THING.
>> Jessica: ESPECIALLY WITH,
WHAT IS IT, 3700 LESS EMPLOYEES?
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY?
>> Jesse: THERE IS A SAUDI SPY
WORKING FOR TWITTER.
WHAT ABOUT THE CHINESE SPY THAT
WAS WORKING FOR HUNTER?
>> Jessica: OH, WE ARE PLAYING
THE WHAT ABOUT GAME?
WHAT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP?
>> Jesse: THAT DOES NOT MAKE
ANY SENSE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE PERFECT EXAMPLE OF A
DEMOCRAT.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
WHAT ABOUT DONALD TRUMP?
...
YOU WEREN'T PREPARED.
>> Jessica: I WAS PLENTY
PREPARED.
SHE FILIBUSTERED AND SHE
FILIBUSTERED.
>> Jesse: I WILL TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS.
THIS WAS A SET UP BY
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
A BLOOMBERG REPORTER, REMEMBER,
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG IS A
BILLIONAIRE, DEMOCRAT DONOR, SO
A BILLIONAIRE, GOT A GUY TO ASK
A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT, DO WE
THINK THIS OTHER RIGHT-LEANING
BILLIONAIRE IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAD?
AND A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT SAID
YEAH, LET'S INVESTIGATE HIM.
THAT WAS A SET UP, AND IT
STINKS.
THAT WAS LITTLE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG RIGHT THERE,
THAT WAS A DIRECT HIT.
>> Jessica: DON'T LITTLE --
>> Jesse: HE IS LITTLE.